ils étaient une vingtaine d'élèves saint
quentinois s'initier au bmx ce mercredi
26 janvier des ateliers ont pris place
au stadium olympique de bmx implanté au
vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux
les athlètes en herbe ont pu découvrir
cette discipline olympique c'est une
activité qui est peu connu mais qu'on a
la chance d'avoir vraiment à proximité
sur notre territoire c'est une activité
nouvelle à sensations fortes que les
élèves aiment beaucoup donc c'est génial
pour eux de pouvoir l'expérimenté
aujourd'hui des ateliers qui
s'inscrivent dans le cadre de la semaine
olympique et paralympique
objectif faire découvrir aux élèves de
saint quentin en yvelines et les sites
olympiques l'initiation s'est déroulée
en trois temps qu'à une partie prise en
main sur le plat avec des petits
exercices d'équilibré ensuite on fait
une partie sur une petite ligne
pumptrack pour qu'ils apprennent à
passer les bosses et en troisième partie
de séance donc à la sur la fin de
l'heure ils vont sur la piste la vraie
piste bmx donc on commence par les
bosses sur la dernière ligne droite
parce que c'est les plus petites bosses
de la pisse ensuite en général on fait
troisième et quatrième lignes et on
finit par un tour complet de piste des
ateliers encadrés par romain racines
l'athlète est arrivé deuxième en
dernière coupe du monde de bmx en élite
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir partager mon
expérience avec eux et également avec
les jeunes de la hesse qui encadrent eux
aussi et du coup au final c'est des
jeunes qu'on encadre en fin moi même que
j'encadre au cours de l'année du coup ça
me permet de tout simplement pouvoir
encadrer les sessions avec eux et de
leur montrer comment cadrer aussi à
notre public
prochain événement vendredi 28 janvier
au programme une randonnée pour
découvrir la colline d'elancourt